[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
richtig leckeres mittag oder abendessen
das könnt ihr auch außerhalb von oma
dann richtig gut vorbereiten und ich
finde es total kindertauglich weil das
einfach richtig cool aussieht wir machen
nämlich hin viele schätze dass in
tomatensoße und um darüber haben wir
noch kleine bällchen aus kartoffeln und
das ganze mit käse überbacken und ich
kam darauf weil ich das einfach mal
zubereitet habe haben mich und dann
fotos geschossen für instagram und euch
abstimmen lassen haben ihr habt gesagt
ja ich drehe das ab und hier sind wir
eine zeige ich euch zuallererst die
zutaten
wir benötigen kartoffeln die habe ich
geschält und in kleine stücke
geschnitten und für die kartoffeln
benötigen wir salz pfeffer und wer mag
noch etwas muskatnuss
außerdem benötigen wir
hähnchenbrustfilets mais erbsen möhren
tomaten das toll wenn das passierte
tomaten zwiebeln und eine knoblauchzehe
außerdem wasser neutrales öl tomaten
oder paprika mark und einen gewürzen
salz und pfeffer edel süßes
paprikapulver getrockneten basilikum
oder oregano und später zum überbacken
noch etwas gouda käse die kartoffeln
gebe ich jetzt in kochendes wasser ich
habe die extra klein geschnitten damit
es schneller geht immer schief ich nicht
ewig zeit und in der zwischenzeit
kümmern wir uns um den rest jetzt habe
ich hier die hähnchenbrust du dir schon
ein kleiner und ein bisschen längliche
stücke geschnitten gibt hier mal ein öl
in die pfanne und brachte das darin gut
an
[Musik]
nach circa vier bis fünf minuten nehmen
wir die hähnchenbrustfilets raus ich
glaube jetzt einfach zurück auf den
teller
und dann geht es nämlich weiter mit
unserer tomatensoße und dafür gebe ich
jetzt in die gleiche fahne mit dem
restmüll die zwiebel mit hinzu und auch
die knoblauchzehe und dünnste das zu
zwei minuten an
[Musik]
nachdem das auf mittlerer stufe ungefähr
drei minuten langen dünnsten durfte
gehen wir jetzt auch paprika marx hinzu
also ich hab jetzt paprika markt
genommen ihr könnt aber auch
selbstverstänlich tomatenmark nehmen und
nach einer minute geben wird dann wie
passierten tomaten hinzu nur in das gut
um und die masse muss jetzt noch mit
etwas wasser verdünnt werden und dabei
auch wieder ständig umrühren so der
nächste schritt sind jetzt die gewürze
die wir mit hinzugeben anschließend
lassen wir das aufkochen und geben unser
gemüse mit rein
[Musik]
schaut euch mal die farben an find das
ist irgendwie das perfekte kinder
mittagessen sowie schulbeginn war ja
auch für erwachsene können an der stelle
auch schon eure hähnchenbrust nochmal
mit dazugeben und wir kümmern uns dann
nämlich um die kartoffeln die sind in
der zwischenzeit nämlich auch schon gar
geworden
die fahne mit dem gemüse mit dem fleisch
köche der zug ganz langsam vor sich hin
und das ganze gemüse wird auch erst im
ofen weil das heißt macht euch hier kein
stress es kommt sowieso gleich noch
alles in den ofen und ich die mit sie
kartoffeln gis die kurz ab und zeigt
euch dann wie es weitergeht so jetzt
habe ich die heißen kartoffeln zurück in
meine schüssel gegeben und wir
verarbeiten sie jetzt auch noch sofort
weiter solange sie noch heiß sind die
heißen kartoffeln werden jetzt entweder
mit einem kartoffel stampfer oder mit
einer gabel richtig schön zerdrückt
zwischendrin dann auch ruhig schon die
gewürze mit rein geben und dann gut
verteilen
[Musik]
die kartoffeln sind soweit vorbereitet
und wir könnten sie zu kugeln rollen
aber meiner meinung nach viel zu heiß
verbringt euch nicht die finger legt für
zehn minuten an die seite und wir machen
so lange weiter nehmen uns dafür eine
auflaufform ich habe so eine
quadratische und da gehen wir schon mal
die gemüse fleisch und tomatensoße
füllungen rein
[Musik]
die kartoffeln sind jetzt aus gewärmt
und ich kann sie anfassen ohne mir die
hände zu verbrennen und ich vor mir
jetzt daraus neun kugeln
[Musik]
und so sieht das ganze schon richtig
richtig lecker aus aber wenn überbacken
das ganze doch mit käse und da findet
euch einfach den käse und 13 ganz
einfach darüber und die jetzt kommt der
allerletzte schritt endlich jetzt wird
der auflauf gebacken im ofen bei 200
grad ober und unterhitze bis das ganze
schön goldbraun geschmolzen ist
und so sieht unser leckere auf pizzen
nach dem backen aus der käse schön
goldbraun und jetzt bekommt jeder ein
stück mit einer leckeren kartoffel kugel
obendrauf ihr könnt das ganze wenn ihr
möchtet noch mit reis servieren ist er
in meinen augen nicht nötig weil das so
schon sehr sättigend ist falls das ganze
jetzt nach koch dass ich sehr hoffe dann
schaut unten in die infobox für die
genauen mengenangaben ansonsten markiert
mich gerne wieder auf instagram mit dem
hashtag iges kitchen und teuren fotos
ich sag bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis
kitchen und ganz viel spaß guten appetit
[Musik]
ok ich glaub ich mach jetzt weiter ich
möchte mich einfach später noch mal bei
euch
ich wünsche jetzt allen hamza also gut
zu sprechen
ich wünsche allen einen schönen abend
ganz viel spaß mit den vorbereitungen
für abendessen mit
[Musik]